people out of Peru we've removed some
and the rest are being removed with the
cooperation of the Peruvian government
and we're also dealing with Honduras on
getting some people out the cat caught
up and we are working on that very well
again with the Honduran government's
work and they're working with us so I
appreciate that we have a couple of
other locations that will report to you
and we were able to get a young woman
released from a certain area who was
being horribly accosted horribly treated
and we spoke to general Milley general
Milley took care of it we went in and we
got her out and we'll we will report
further on that one but it's there was
rough stuff I want to thank general
Milley I want to thank all of the people
that were were involved and the people
that went in together I want to thank
you very much as we continue to marshal
every resource at America's disposal in
the fight against the Chinese virus
we're profoundly grateful to our
nation's state and local leaders doctors
nurses law enforcement and first
responders who are waging this battle on
the ground it is absolutely critical
that Americans continue to follow the
federal government's guidelines so
important about social distancing
non-essential travel and hand-washing
defeating this unseen enemy requires the
help and commitment of every single
American I want to just say that Senator
Rand Paul a friend of mine he's been a
great friend of mine he's been always
there when we needed him when the
country needed him and as you know he
just tested positive Jose diaz-balart
spoke to him yesterday tested positive
and
so people are they're getting quite
close to home and it's a terrible thing
that's going on the hidden enemy I call
it the hidden enemy and I think they'll
all be fine I hope they're gonna be fine
but I just want to send our regards and
I think I can speak on behalf of our
country to those two great friends of
mine who are working urgently with
Congress on legislation to support the
millions of workers small businesses and
industries who have been hit hard by the
virus through no fault of their own our
goal is to get relief to Americans as
quickly as possible so that families can
get by and small businesses can keep
workers on the payroll this will help
our economy and you will see our economy
skyrocket once this is over I think it's
going to skyrocket it's a it's a pent up
demand it's a built up demand and I
guess you really have to say who knows
but I think it's going to be a
tremendous day when we win this war we
will win the war we want to win the war
was a with as few AF if you look at it
just deaths as possible we want to have
as few number of deaths as possible
today I'm announcing action to help New
York California and Washington ensure
that the National Guard can effectively
respond to this crisis the National
Guard these are tremendous people
they're fully on alert we've signed what
we had to sign and it's been activated
we're dealing also with other states
these states have been hit the hardest
actually pretty much by far you could
say the hardest everybody can see that
just look at the numbers and through
FEMA the federal government will be
funding 100% of the cost of deploying
National Guard units to carry out
approved missions to stop the virus well
those governors remain in command so the
governors locally are going to be in
command and we'll be following them and
we hope they can do the job and I think
they will I spoke with
all three of the governor's today and
just a little while ago and they're very
happy with what we're going to be doing
because we will be announcing some other
things for those three states and some
other states where it's hit the hardest
this action will give them maximum
flexibility to use the guard against the
virus without having to worry about cost
reliability and freeing up state
resources to protect the health and
safety of the people in their state the
federal government has deployed hundreds
of tons of supplies from our national
stockpile to locations with the greatest
need in order to assist in those areas I
approved the state of New York's request
for a major disaster declaration
something which Governor Cuomo has been
asking for and which I agree and we had
it done in very rapid fashion we
approved this on Friday evening and we
are working very very hard to get all of
these things not only signed up but
completed and finished and in wind the
request from the state of Washington for
a major disaster declaration was
approved just a little while ago went
through the process and we moved it very
quickly the request from the state of
California was just received and we will
have it approved very quickly we'll be
working I told that to Gavin Newsom and
we are we're working on getting that
done very quickly it'll be done maybe
tonight we've large we have large
quantities of medical equipment and
supplies on the way based on all of this
to those states including respirators
surgical masks and gowns face shields
coveralls and gloves with large
quantities already delivered to
Washington and to New York in addition a
large quantities of supplies I've also
directed FEMA to supply the following
four large federal medical stations with
1,000 beds for New York eight large
federal medical stations with 2,000 beds
for California and three large federal
medical stations and for small federal
medical stay
with 1000 beds for the state of
Washington
the governor's know the supplies in
route to California and New York will be
delivered within the next 48 hours in
addition the naval hospital ship the
USNS mercy
it's incredible ships these two ships
are incredible one of the West Coast one
of the East Coast will be deployed to
Los Angeles to add emergency surge
medical capacity and they have a
tremendous capacity they are really
something I will say that if you look at
some of the things we've been doing and
now those numbers have gone up and just
to be a little bit more exacting we've
done a presidential approval for a
request for major disaster declaration
for the state of New York
approval of title 32 National Guard
activation for the state of New York
we're providing all of this at no cost
to the governor
I spoke with Governor Cuomo he's working
hard we're all working hard together the
relationship has really been amazing but
it also enables the governor to provide
robust National Guard support to the
state and the 25 percent we're going to
be waiving that 25 percent cost we're
picking up we'll be coordinating and
they'll be doing something with very
special people mission assignment of the
US Army Corps of Engineers to provide
support to build out alternate care
sites they're doing various alternate
care sites which have now been
designated by New York for large federal
medical stations of 1,000 beds these are
very complex places actually with great
equipment and great people strategic
national stockpile order and this is as
of a number of days ago so far delivered
to New York and this is the 19th we had
the n95 respirators 186,000 416
delivered
we've delivered four hundred and
forty-four thousand Oh seventy-eight
surgical masks many have been delivered
since then facials we've delivered
eighty four thousand five hundred and
sixty face shields surgical vans
surgical gowns sixty eight thousand nine
forty four to New York coveralls three
hundred and fifty two gloves 245,000
four eighty-six also to New York in
terms of what's been delivered just
since then the numbers are quite large
and we have tremendous numbers of
companies also making equipment for the
state of Washington we've delivered
three hundred and sixty nine thousand
n95 respirators five hundred and seven
thousand four hundred and six surgical
masks and this is as of about three days
ago
facial sixty three thousand seven
hundred and eighty-eight face shields
surgical gowns one hundred and seven
thousand eight fifty gloves two hundred
and forty thousand 376 and we have many
many things pending it's actually not
pending it's being being fabricated
they're being made and they're moving
now for Washington so we have four small
federal medical stations 250 bits and
for Washington state of Washington we
have three large federal medical
stations 750 bits and then you have as I
said the approval of the title 32
National Guard state of California again
to be very precise we're going to have
the approval of the title 32 National
Guard activation and we're providing all
of this again at like in New York at no
cost to the governor meaning the
governor Newsom and the state no cost to
the state it enables the governor to
provide robust
National Guard support to the state so
they're going to have control of the
I'll guard federal government sending
these are incredible people that are
being sent we have eight large federal
medical stations with over 2,000 beds
and that's going to California and then
strategic national stockpile order we've
ordered likewise hundreds of thousands
of different items won't go into the
exact numbers but the numbers are very
substantial but we're having tremendous
additional numbers said and whatever the
states can get they should be getting I
say we're sort of a backup for the
states and some of the states are doing
really well and some don't do as well
the ones that don't do as well need more
help but these are three states that
really do need help because they are
they are hit very hard and the
outpouring from the private sector has
also been extraordinary I'm pleased to
report that Honeywell great company has
just announced it will immediately
expand its personal protective equipment
manufacturing operations in Rhode Island
to produce millions of additional n95
mass a very hard to get they're actually
quite complex for the US government
strategic national stockpile they'll be
immediately then delivered to the
various states this expansion is already
underway and it's going to provide a lot
of jobs for that state probably around
500 the masks will be distributed by the
government for the use of the health
safety and emergency and this for
response workers primarily for response
workers these are very high-end this
expansion is in addition to honeywell's
action to more than double production of
its existing personal protective
equipment manufacturing plants and make
a lot of different things and they're
doubling and tripling their production
they're going round the clock today I'm
also announcing the launch of a new
public private consortium organized by
the White House the Department of Energy
and IBM - at least the power of American
supercomputing resources to fight the
Chinese virus the following leaders from
private industries academia and
government will be contributing
and they're gonna be contributing a lot
of different things but computer
primarily computing resources to help
researchers discover new treatments and
vaccines they'll be working along with
NIH and all of the people that are
working on this but tremendous help from
IBM Amazon Google Microsoft MIT
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute the
Department of Energy's national labor
laboratories the National Science
Foundation and NASA they're all
contributing to this effort and they're
fully in gear this afternoon I also want
to update you on the steps who are
taking to protect and serve our
countries 18 million veterans these are
great people are amazing veterans have
shown their eternal loyalty to our
nation and this is the time were there
in need and we are going to show our
loyalty to them were being very
protective of our veterans we're working
on certain hospitals where we may be
doing some work in Louisiana in
particular and some other states
Veterans Hospitals it'll be very
protective of our veterans some of them
are of that very vulnerable age and some
of them obviously are not feeling well
and some of them are still suffering the
wounds of war for many years ago
yesterday are signed vital legislation
to ensure that the GI Bill will cover
distance learning during this emergency
I also spoke with many of our veterans
service organizations or the VSOs to
describe our unprecedented action in
February the Department of Veterans
Affairs established 19 emergency
operation centers throughout the country
one of the things that they've been
trying to get done for many years you
all know this from following me over the
last number of years but we got it done
pretty quickly they've been trying to
get it done for many many decades with
choice veterans choice and also veterans
accountability now if it's if it's
crowded within this if they can't get to
a doctor we have great
kurz in the VA I have to say that we
have fantastic doctors as good as they
come
but it's hard to get to them because of
what was bureaucracy but no longer
bureaucracy we've done a lot of things
in that case because of accountability
when people aren't doing their jobs or
if they're bad or if they're sadistic or
if they steal or anything bad happens
we're now allowed to fire them for I
signed that a year and a half ago for
many years you weren't able to do this
so the VA is working and I was just told
by a great leader at the VA Robert
Robert Wilkie he said for the first time
we get the highest marks in the history
highest poll numbers in the history of
the Veterans Administration came out a
week ago that they're happy and look one
of the reasons that happened highest in
history one of the reasons that happened
is because of veterans choice if they
have to wait on line they go and see a
private doctor we pay the bill and and
they get better they don't have to wait
two weeks and three weeks or two days
but they get better and a lot of times
they waited so long that they would they
would have a problem and it would end up
being terminal because they couldn't get
the kind of treatment that is there they
deserve so highest poll numbers highest
approval numbers in the history of the
VA I was just given that information
yesterday we restricted visitors access
to 135 veteran community living centers
which has nearly 8,000 veterans with
chronic medical conditions so that we
limit their exposure to the virus we
want to totally take care of our
veterans and that's what we're doing the
VA has cancelled most elective medical
and surgical procedures that delaying
them till after this is gone after we've
won
we began providing life-saving care to
patients who had symptoms across the 171
VA medical centers nationwide that's a
big deal under my administration the VA
has also been a leader
and expanding telehealth telehealth is
becoming a bigger and bigger factor in
in medicine this month we have taken
bold action to cut through the red tape
and make telehealth available for
millions more Americans during this
crisis they can speak to a doctor from
the safety of their home rather than
risk becoming infected or making a
tremendously long trip when frankly
you'll speak to a great doctor right
from your home it's happening telehealth
we're very much at the forefront of that
- we're very proud of it and it also
takes a big burden off our system we
continue to accelerate the development
of safe and effective vaccines
we're also aggressively investigating a
number of antiviral therapies and
treatments to determine their potential
and reducing the severity and duration
of the symptoms and you know how I feel
because how I feel is on Tuesday they're
going to be starting it on Tuesday
morning and we're gonna have some
medications delivered that we're gonna
see if they work they certainly are
effective in other ways and they they
are safe from the standpoint is that
they're not they're not killing people
we're not gonna have that so a lot of
great things have been happening in that
regard I just want to finish and then
we're going to ask a couple of people to
say a few words that have been so much
in the forefront of this incredible job
that we've all been given but I want to
say that I know that this is a
challenging time for all Americans
we're enduring a great national trial
and we will prove that we can meet at
the moment I want to assure the American
people that we're doing everything we
can each day to confront and ultimately
defeat this horrible invisible enemy
we're at war and a true sense were at
war and we're fighting an invisible
enemy think of that for those of you who
are feeling alone and isolated I want
you to know that we are all joined
together as one people eternally linked
by our shared Nash
spirit we love our country the spirit of
courage and love and patriotism no
American is alone as long as we are
united and we are united we're very
United people are saying things now that
three weeks ago they didn't talk that
way
we're very United no force is equal to
the strength of a unit really a unified
America United America and America like
we have it right now for those word and
afraid please know as long as I am your
president you can feel confident that
you have a leader who will always fight
for you and I will not stop until we win
this will be a great victory this is
going to be a victory and it's going to
be a victory that in my opinion will
happen much sooner than originally
expected it's now attacking the enemy is
attacking 144 countries at this moment
144 that's unthinkable there's never
been anything like this and it's vicious
it is vicious some people recover well
and some people have a hard time we all
know that but we will be totally
victorious we will then get our economy
up to a level that it was and I in my
opinion beyond because that will be a
pent up demand there is a pent up demand
and a lot of a lot of great things will
happen but I'm very proud of our country
I'm very proud I'm very proud to be your
president and it's just something that's
just you're very special people so thank
you very much and I'm gonna ask if I
might combination to Pete why don't you
start off very pleased Thank You mr.
president
all right just a little bit about what
we're doing in Washington California and
New York we understand that the states
of Washington New York in California the
era seen a steady increase in the voter
19 virus cases in order to assist with
additional needs identified in those
areas the state of New York was approved
for a major disaster and
this morning Washington State was also
approved earlier today California
submitted their request and the
president will consider it immediately
we have medical supplies enroute to
these states including respirators
surgical masks gowns facial coveralls
gloves with quantities already delivered
to both Washington New York and
California and we anticipate additional
supplies to be delivered with the next
42 hours to all these states under
president Trump's unprecedented national
emergency declaration on March 13 FEMA
is assisting state local tribal and
territory governments including
reimbursing eligible emergency
protective measures taken at the
directional guidance of public health
officials in response to this emergency
all 50 states the District of Columbia
five territories and two tribes are
working directly with FEMA under the
nationwide emergency declaration for
kovetz 19 with the assistance of the
FEMA regional administrators were
throughout the country we are working to
address the needs of state and local
officials everywhere States tribal and
territorial governments do not need to
request separate emergency declarations
to receive FEMA assistance under this
nationwide declaration the emergency
declaration does not authorize direct
financial assistance available to
individuals such as disaster
unemployment assistance or other needs
assistance at this time just a note on
the USNS mercy based on analysis of
potential needs for hospital beds on the
west coast the decision was made that
the USNS hospital ship mercy would have
the greatest impact in California the
Department of Defense has been given
direction to dispatch it to Los Angeles
immediately DoD has advised that the
mercy can get into position within a
week or less of today's order even
though there are more cases right now in
Washington the projected needs for beds
in California is five times more of more
that of Washington the mercy will be
used to take pressure off local
hospitals all the medical needs and not
for treating kovin 19 cases and finally
a little bit about the National Guard
the federal government continues to take
aggressive action in proactive steps
to address the Cova 19 threat as we
attack the health and safety or protect
the health and safety of American people
it remains our top priority the National
Guard is especially pasta in equipped to
assist federal state local agencies
while serving the public in response to
this unprecedented nationwide operation
President Trump has approved Washington
California New York National Guard units
under title 30 fight excuse me title 32
status for the coded 19 response the
president's action provide the nation's
governor's continued command of the
National Guard forces enabling States to
use additional resources to meet the
missions necessary in the Cova 19
response the National Guard is a viable
and responsive avenue to provide a much
needed asset that its state managed and
federally supported and I want to be
clear this title 32 activation does not
federalize National Guard members the
National Guard is still under the
authority of each governor they will
work in concert with the Department of
Defense and we've had a lot of distance
misinformation circling and I want to
make sure it is understood that this is
not martial law the Department of
Defense by way of a mission assignment
will lead this task and then finally we
continue to respond to hundreds of
requests from governor's across the
country and filling all their critical
needs thank you sir
Thank You mr. president good evening but
what I want to talk briefly about is the
defense production act and and to give
you the overview here using the full
power of private enterprise and you full
force in the federal government my job
at the White House is to make sure
tactically working with FEMA and HHS is
the American people particularly our
health care professionals get the gloves
the masks and all of the personal
protective equipment they need and I can
tell you sir that since you signed
defense production Act my job got me and
let me explain why the defense
production act in this context has two
primary functions one is
globalization of the industrial base in
this case the public health industrial
base and the other is allocation of
resources both from the supply chain to
the manufacturers and from the
manufacturers to the end-users such as
the healthcare professionals now what
we're seeing on a purely voluntary basis
based on the leadership of this
administration we're seeing the greatest
mobilization in the industrial base
since World War two and every day I'm
working with organizations and companies
National Association of manufacturing
the National Council of textile
organizations and so on in terms of
building up rapidly our capabilities to
get what you need now let's think about
what mobilization means it can mean for
example repurposing a factory so Pernod
Ricard called us last week and they had
three hurdles they had to deal with they
called my office had to make a call to
Treasury FDA and HHS to clear the path
we got that done that day they started
their production that day moving from
alcoholic beverages to hand sanitizers
and as we speak a truck is moving
towards New York and will arrive there
Tuesday to share with the hospitals over
a thousand gallons of sanitizers so that
would be that would be a repurpose a
second example would be one that
President had offered with with
Honeywell again Honeywell called the
White House asking for help from from
the president and what they said is look
we want to do this new factory in
Smithfield Rhode Island they called me
on a Friday morning and by that night we
had a contract in to HHS HHS flipped
that immediately and I had Honeywell
moving people and equipment from
Massachusetts to that facility in
Smithfield Rhode Island and we're going
to have those masks produced within 30
days moving on the assembly chain so my
point is mobilization is repurposing
building up capabilities and the
the other portion is of course the
allocation of resources now what I can
tell you so far is that the defense
production actor has given me quiet
leverage when you have a strong leader
you can take a light hand initially and
so what we've seen with this outpouring
of volunteers from private enterprise
we're getting what we need without
without putting the heavy hand of
government down there will be possibly
cases down the road and the
manufacturers have actually asked me and
alerted me this where some places in the
supply chain they may have problems that
the White House will have to break
through using the defense production act
we won't hesitate to do that
the last thing I'll tell you is that I
also get a lot of calls that are very
disquieting brokers are offering
millions of items where their goggles
masked or whatever and you go through
three different brokers tracing to a
warehouse in LA that allegedly got 10
million masks and they want to charge
you seven times what they cost that's
price gouging we are a message to the
hoarders if you got any large quantities
of material that this country needs
right now get them to market or get them
to us we'll pay you a fair price but if
you don't do that we're going to come
for you and make sure that doesn't
happen in this country and that would be
a good use of the defense production Act
so I salute you sir you've made my job
easier and I appreciate that Thank You
mr. president
task force met this afternoon as we do
every day and let me begin today by
simply saying thank you to the American
people and thank you for the way that
people across this country seven days in
- 15 days to slow the spread the people
in communities large and small across
America are responding are cooperating
are communicating not just on behalf of
their own health and the health of their
family but more importantly on behalf of
the most vulnerable among us so on
behalf of your president and our entire
task force just thank you to the
American people
I also want to express our appreciation
to the governor's across the country
president today just announced action in
New York California and Washington State
as the latest demonstration that this
administration will do whatever it takes
to support the leadership at the state
and local level as as the American
people confront the spread of the corona
virus the legislative efforts that are
underway being negotiated on Capitol
Hill as we speak
the bipartisan spirit that's taking
place there that's reflected in all of
our interactions with state leaders
around the country is a great credit to
the nation but it should be a great
encouragement to the American people
that that your government at the federal
level at the state level working with
courageous health care providers all
across America coming together to meet
this moment and that is the way our
system works it's extremely important
that the American people recognize that
one of the things that makes America
different is that we have a system of
federalism and that the the by putting
FEMA in the lead the president has
emphasized that our response to the
corona virus is in in the anthem of FEMA
theme FEMA it is locally executed state
managed and federally supported we want
the people on the ground the
decision-makers to have what they need
we want States to be able to manage the
unique circumstances in their States and
whether it be the legislation moving
through the Congress or this the efforts
the president announced today major
disaster declarations title 32 on the
National Guard resources flowing
hospital beds flowing we're going to
continue to make sure that our states
have what they need and to meet this
moment our task force continues to focus
on the priorities president's given us
they are testing mitigation and supplies
and on the subject of testing as is
evident to people across the country
testing is more and more available every
single day we'll be detailing tomorrow
from this podium the progress that we
are making on tests at this day's
reporting 205
54,000 Americans have been tested and
received results in corona virus test
with slightly more than than 30,000
actually testing positive there's a bit
of an encouraging word in that for every
American remember everyone that's being
tested now with the exception of our
health care workers our people that have
symptoms that make them think they may
have the corona virus and as our numbers
come in consistently because the 254,000
does not include all the local hospitals
or all the local labs in our states it's
working out to be about one in ten
Americans who've been tested who thought
they had corona virus actually had it
nine out of ten did not but we'll
continue to roll out the testing to
provide that resource to the American
people and we're working to make testing
happen faster we expect from word from
the commercial labs that we should be
caught up on the backlog in testing by
the middle of the week and we are urging
today on the president's behalf that all
labs would prioritize in patient testing
let me say again to all of the
commercial labs in the country you will
receive guidance from HHS tomorrow but
on behalf of the president and the White
House coronavirus Task Force we are
urging all commercial labs to prioritize
in patient testing we want people that
have been checked into a hospital that
are being treated for what they suspect
to be corona virus to receive those
tests more quickly also I'm pleased to
report that yesterday the FDA approved
an emergency authorization on a new test
that should be in production by the end
of March it actually would be a corona
virus test the results of which come
back in 45 minutes and we're also
working on the FDA is working with
manufacturers around the country to come
up with even faster more innovative
tests and as we told our governors in
several calls this week governors and
state health officials to simply contact
FEMA for the latest information on
testing solutions let me also say
tomorrow when we gather at this podium
we'll be unveiling
dr. Bob Redfield in the lead new
guidance for people that work in law
enforcement first responders people that
work in what we call critical
infrastructure in the country it was in
early March the CDC issued guidance for
people that were asymptomatic or did not
have symptoms but who had been exposed
to someone with coronavirus who gave
them guidance about being able to return
to work wearing a mask for 14 days and
tomorrow at this podium CDC will unveil
in cooperation with the Department of
Homeland Security new guidance which
will make it possible for people that
have been exposed to return to work more
click quickly with by wearing a mask for
a certain period of time let me also
amplify a point on behalf of the
President and on behalf of the State
Department about Americans abroad now
one of the one of the reasons why the
United States is in a different position
today then portions of Europe are and
China and elsewhere is because the
president suspended all travel from
China he suspended travel from Europe
and the UK in Ireland but the State
Department is working around the clock
to assist Americans who may find
themselves overseas they're able to come
home there's no barrier to Americans
coming back to American soil they're
screened when they come home through a
series of airports but we're aware that
with flights being canceled some
Americans have found themselves unable
to find a way home and as the president
said we've been working very diligently
through the State Department to make it
possible their commercial flights have
been chartered we're also working with
the military for a backup on flights at
this point the State Department has
brought more than 3000 Americans back
home but speaking to the Secretary of
State today he wanted me to share a
website and a phone number for any
American that might be looking on from
overseas you can call the smart traveler
enrollment program at one eight eight
eight four zero seven four seven four
seven or you can go online at step dot
state.gov this will allow our embassy
and consulates to gather important
information about your situation and
work to facilitate to bring you home let
me say finally as I began let me close
as the chairman or the leader of this
White House coronavirus task force we
are seven days into 15 days and the
American people are responding because
as we speak about supplies as we speak
about testing the most important thing
every American can do is heed the
guidance in the direction from your
state and local officials particularly
in areas where we have widespread
coronavirus infections but for every
American putting into practice these
measures that the president alluded to
at the very beginning of his remarks is
a way that we can that we can do this
America we can we can lessen the
magnitude of the corona virus in our
country with the cooperation compassion
generosity and prayers of the American
people we can slow the spread we can
protect the most vulnerable and we can
heal our land so let's do it America
thank you thank you very much so just a
couple of little things that we'll take
some questions
maybe you will have some maybe you want
that'll be a shock you shot the American
public but I have to say on the testing
they knew if we if this works out and we
think it might the new test will be a
very simple one of much easier than the
existing test which is quite complex and
not not a lot of fun to take and this
will be a game changer but remember we
inherited a broken obsolete system it
was good for a small number of people
but not good for the millions of people
that we're talking about and we've made
this into a system that no matter where
you go in the world that's where they're
going that's what they want to do that's
how they're going to be doing it should
something like this happen again so our
people have done a fantastic job really
a fantastic job and I hope the new test
works out we'll know fairly soon I think
we're gonna be knowing about that very
soon hopefully it'll check out or test
out and we certainly are looking forward
to that that'll be a very simple test by
comparison won't be unpleasant at all
and one other thing the the ships so we
have the mercy and that's in it's going
to California as you know that's in on
the west coast now and you have a sister
ship that's essentially a twin they're
incredible I mean they're incredible
ships I've seen it I've seen one of them
and they are unbelievable what they can
do in the capacity many operating rooms
you know their wartime ships they're
meant for war many many operating rooms
stainless steel these rooms are as good
as there is anywhere in the nation
actually I spoke with Governor Cuomo
with a great conversation today number
of conversations actually is working
very hard and we are going to be
bringing that ship that's called the
comfort so you have the mercy and the
comfort the comforts on the East Coast
and that chip will be coming over the
next three weeks three or four weeks
that's being it was in the middle of
maintenance and we are moving the
maintenance very very quickly and we're
also supplying the ship simultaneously
it's actually big supplies going into
those ships big and that ship will be
coming up here over the next few weeks
and we'll probably be putting it in New
York Harbor and we're making
arrangements for that also as to where
it's going to be docked so you have the
mercy and you have the comfort they'll
be coming up the Mercy will start very
very quickly it'll be arriving in Los
Angeles pretty soon so we look forward
to that a question ABC
first of all Senator Paul testing
positive once the last time you had in
person contact with on top of Senator
Paul now four senators are in isolation
and the rules say that in order to vote
there one of the senator Rick Scott also
two of them were in contact with Rick is
going out with the critical stimulus
package vote expect Romney's imagination
yes gee that's too bad
I do you think that Congress should
consider changing the rules to allow
them to vote remotely if it comes to
this critical stimulus I was thinking
about it today and I'm saying you know
you could have a lot of senators and a
lot of House members I spoke last night
with a very very good man who happens to
be in the house as you know and he's
he's just started and he tested positive
so you could have a large number of
people and they're from Congress you
could have between House and Senate you
could have a large number and I think
it's something at least I mean I fully
understand why you should be there I
think it may be a constitutional reason
why you should but we could be in a
position where I would certainly be in
favor of it where they could vote from a
certain outside location I would be in
favor I was thinking about it today I
mean we could be in this look with
what's going on nobody's ever seen
anything like this you could have a lot
of people in there from from Congress
and it was it would certainly be they
may tell me there's a reason
constitutionally and there may be but I
would be totally in favor of it on a
temporary basis negotiations still have
a ways to go on the stimulus package are
you concerned about the timing at all we
have we have an interesting thing you
know we we all want to get to the same
place but we've different I have we want
to and I just wrote this down just a
little while ago we want to protect the
worker very much so do they so to the
Democrats
we also want to protect the worker
through their companies we don't want to
necessarily we're gonna help the worker
anyway but ideally they can go back to
one of their great companies you know
you have great companies that
in financial trouble now and we need
money to help those companies so they
get back into where they should be
health you know most of these companies
four weeks ago were having the best year
they've ever had last year was the best
year almost all of them other than
Boeing which is incredibly had problems
big percentage of GDP but we have to be
able to work with Boeing Boeing is was a
great company and we'll be a great
company again I think shortly so we have
to work with the companies and they
don't want to do that it's crazy they
don't want to do that
I don't want stock buybacks so I don't
know where the problem is there but I
know that's one of the things that
they're talking about I do not want
stock buybacks I don't want to give a
bailout to a company and then have
somebody go out and use that money to
buy back stock in the company and raise
the price and and then get a bonus okay
so I may be Republican but I don't like
that I want them to use the money for
the workers I want them to use the money
for the company to help the company in
the airline business to take care of
their planes and all of the things they
have to do polluting by buying new
planes but I don't want to type start I
don't want to have any stock buybacks
the Democrats are with me I don't know
what the problem is in that one because
I can't imagine that is too tough we
want to we want to be able to take care
of our people you're going to have
things coming up we're going to have
some of some of the elements that
they're talking about they're down to I
mean literally 95% of things that you
would think that they wouldn't agree and
you think the Republicans wouldn't agree
to it and unemployment as an example is
one of the things they talk about an
unemployment insurance I think we're
very close on that but you know right
now they're not so right now they're not
there but I think that the Democrats
want to get there and I can tell you for
a fact the Republicans want to get there
and I don't think anybody actually has a
choice
it's a bold package it's a big package
we do have money for what are the things
is we do have money for saving small
businesses I don't imagine the Democrats
because we have a lot of money set aside
for small businesses we also have a lot
of money set aside for big businesses
you know the big
powerful companies that were powerful
four weeks ago and today they're
overextended look at the cruise line
that's a big that's a tremendous
business a big business very important
to Florida and it's unthinkable a month
ago a month just unthinkable that was
setting all sorts of records they were
they're building new ships we can't let
the cruise line lines go out of business
I mean that would be massive numbers of
jobs for our country and actually for
the world but for our country it's a
massive business and it doesn't take
much to keep them going so we have to we
have to provide for that but I think
both the Democrats and the Republicans
are agreed that we have to take care of
our workers and we're going to be doing
that in numerous ways including a
substantial cash payment yeah please
when it comes to the defense production
act we know that government across the
country all day today we're pleading
with you to eautiful to utilize the dpa
why not use it now if that would answer
their pleas for help but we are using it
now the fact that I signed it it's in
effect but you know we're a country not
based on nationalizing our business call
a person over in Venezuela ask them how
did nationalization of their businesses
work out not too well the concept of
nationalizing our business is not a good
concept but I'll tell you why as Peter
said we may have to use it someplace
along the chain but we're getting calls
here's the beauty of it if we go out and
we want let's say masks we don't know
who to call learn mask but Hanes who
makes things of cotton various elements
lots of things it's a great company they
called us and they said we're going to
make millions of masks we got a call
today from 3m there's a big article
today the head of 3m they're going to
make tremendous products and they're
more or less in that business and if
they're not like for instance General
Motors spoke to us Ford spoke to us
about doing ventilators the beauty is
they're calling us if you go the
National Rock nationalization route
we're going to tell a company to make a
ventilator they don't even know what a
ventilator is
in the case of one company they used to
make them years ago and they know how to
make them you know it's a very complex
piece of equipment frankly so what we're
doing is I think Peter said it maybe
better than anybody's gonna say it we
have the threat of doing it if we need
it we may have to use it somewhere along
the supply chain in a minor way but we
have millions of masks being done we
have respirators we have ventilators we
have a lot of things happening right now
so just a threat of using it but using
it's actually a big deal I mean when
this was announced it said tremors
through our business community and
through our country because basically
what are you doing you're talking about
you're gonna nationalize an industry or
you're gonna nationalize you're gonna
take away companies you're gonna tell
companies what to do the truth is most
people nobody would know where to start
there are companies out there that you
wouldn't think of that have called us
that say we can do ventilators we used
to do them years ago and they can do
them in large quantities other company
if I call companies and say you build
ventilators they don't even know what a
ventilator is so it's really working out
very well one of the reasons I read the
numbers to you is because we've given
vast numbers of just about everything
we've taken it out of our supply out of
our supply and we're restocking our
supply but we're really backing up the
governor's the governor's have to go out
do their things and you have a lot of
Governors they've done a fantastic job
you have some that haven't usually it's
the ones that complain that have the
problems but we've had a great
relationship as an example with Governor
Cuomo with governor Newsom we've had a
great relationship with the state of
Washington those are three hot bets
those are three hot beds now we're also
dealing with other states as the Admiral
said yesterday we're doing with all of
the states actually in one form or
another some are very affected in a very
minor way where you have two people or
three people and I don't even mean
deaths I mean literally cases and that's
different than New York where you have
you know tremendous where everybody I
lived there for a long time everybody's
extremely close tight and you have a lot
of cases in New York you have a lot of
cases in New York
and we're helping Governor Cuomo we're
helping governor Newsom
they've been frankly they've been total
gentlemen they want to get it done and
we want to get it done but doing doing
it the way we're doing it is much better
it's really much better not it's about
allocation not about manufacturing so
the companies we coordinate with the
states and we are coordinated with the
states and for the most part the
coordination has been a very good look
three days ago I had a phone call with
all the governors I actually allowed the
press to stay they weren't supposed to
stay and one person in the media said
that was surprising it's actually a
little risky doing that because we had
Democrats and we had Republicans and you
know they're politicians and they always
have something to say well I took a lot
of calls and we really didn't get one
nasty or bad response they were thanking
us for the job we did and I had to press
the end I don't know if you were there I
don't think so
I had the press standing there watching
they weren't supposed to be there but I
said let him stand there the governors
were very complimentary very very
complimentary and I watched I watched
over the last few days Governor Cuomo I
watched a gavin newsom with california
watch both of them and they've been you
know very complimentary and those are
really the hot beds and so we want to
keep that going I'm very proud of this
country and I'm frankly very proud of a
lot of the politicians that normally
we're fighting with we have different
views on things you know a little
different view but we're going to get to
the same place we have different views
but we're going to get to the same place
yeah please I wanted to ask if you are
considering an executive order to free
elderly non violent criminals from
federal prisons we have been asked about
that and we're going to take a look at
it it's a it's a bit of a problem but
when we talk about totally nonviolent
we're talking about user totally
nonviolent prisoners we are actually
looking at that yes
your administration eliminated a key
position in China in July a medical
epidemiologist imbedded in China's
Disease Control Agency and it was just
months before the first cases were
spotted in Wuhan so the question is
basically why the post was eliminated
anybody would you like to take that one
Bob but but you know this is just like
all of the other stuff that you not you
but that the press was asking all of
which turned out to be we actually gave
CDC more money not less money they said
we defunded it turned out it was more
money every one of those things that
were said were 100% wrong and this
sounds like another one of them but
anyway go ahead yeah
as you know CDC has offices all around
the world right now to do our function
to detect and prevent and respond to
outbreaks where they occur the china
office is actually being augmented as we
speak as and we've been embedded there
for over 30 years there's a reason they
call it the Chinese CDC because we've
had that productive partnership again
our relationship with Chen is a very
good relationship I wish they told us
three months sooner that this was a
problem we didn't know about it they
knew about it and they should have told
us we could have saved a lot of lives
throughout the world if you look at
what's happening in Italy in Spain and a
lot of other countries we could have
saved a lot of lives throughout the
world Kelly give the diagnosis for
Senator Paul and people being a self
quarantine what concerns do you have
about the direct threat to the function
of this
the ability to get this important
passage that people are waiting for past
and should Americans be expecting you to
extend the 15 days given the climate of
how this is spreading if you hope we
won't have to it's possible but we'll
have to see how that works as far as the
Senate is concerned we are looking at
some you know some of the folks are
feeling very good
some are quarantined but they're
negative they may be they may be it may
be totally fine okay
others are positive we're just finding
this now for the first time I mean over
the last two days we found that threat
to the aid package that Americans are
waiting for no I don't see any threats
at all honestly I don't see any threats
at all it'll all work out
it is a question and a very good
question I thought that we are
considering I don't know if you can do
it constitutionally but we are
considering letting people vote
Senators Congressmen and women vote from
a separate from a separate location from
a outside namely a hospital or a home
depending on where they are so we are
looking at that it's a little trickier
question most people would believe but
we are looking at that very strongly
Kelly was alluding to it while we've
been up here they weren't able to get
into 60 votes to move the package for
the cloture vote
I'm just curious just your reaction to
that sir and then what is Mitch
McConnell telling you and secretary
knows what we're dealing with them all
the time and we're dealing with Mitch
we're dealing with the other side
everybody wants to get there we'll see
what happens I think you'll I think
you'll get there it's but to me it's not
very complicated we have to help the
worker we have to save the companies
because as soon as we're finished with
this war it's not a battle it's a war
the Sooners were finished with this war
our country is going to bounce back like
you've never seen before
but we have to get it to that position
and we have to make sure that those
companies are whole that they haven't
been disbanded because if you do that
it's going to take much longer so in a
way it's being Pennywise if you're done
but we want to help the worker we want
to help the companies that the workers
come from because if those companies go
out of business and that includes small
businesses
a tremendous amount of small-business
working there you know that once they go
out and they don't come back
that's a much longer period of building
sir I apologize if there was a woman
that was an American that was was she
being tortured what was going on there
bad things were happening to her in a
certain country and we're we're really
under the feeling that we should keep it
somewhat private until she's already
been freed and I have to tell you
general Milley and the his people were
unbelievable they were not playing games
general Milley does not play games it's
very interesting guy they got her out
where she was seriously abused accosted
and and whatever the maximum word is
other than death that happened but we
got her out and she's okay and she's
back with her parents got two speakers
but previous crises like the tsunami
Katrina past presidents they've they
call their predecessors and said hey I
need you to step in do something like
that do you have any interest in
reaching out to Presidents Bush Obama
Clinton Carter I'm just curious if
that's meaningful consider enough look I
have the best people in the world I
think we're doing an extraordinary job
if you look at if you look in let's say
the h1n1 you look at that hole that was
a disaster that was a tough period of
time for our country you look at so many
other things that weren't handled very
well whether it's Katrina or something
else look I respect everybody but I feel
I have an incredible team and I think
we're doing an incredible job when you
look at the job we're doing and what you
have to do is look at the approval
numbers on the job we're doing I think
we're doing an incredible job so I don't
want to disturb them bother them I don't
think I'm going to learn much and you
know I guess you could say that there's
probably a natural inclination not to
call now if I felt that if I called I'd
learned something and that would save
one life it would save one life okay I
would make the call in two minutes but I
don't see that happening please
but the comments in a couple of your
former aides have said today Gary Cohen
us that is it time to start discussing
the need for a date when the economy can
turn back on where's the man and his
saying drop the hammer stay on the virus
we're gonna have to take the thing up
front you have to shut it all down
I suppose one asks with the tension
between the economic game was suffering
and of course the virus itself and the
casualty of America I'm of the opinion
we have to do great during this 14 days
during the 15-day period we'll know at
the end of 14 days pretty much we're
gonna have a pretty good idea how we're
doing I think you have to shut it down
and you have to see but you know
there'll be a point at which we say
we're back in business let's go Safety's
are not mutually exclusive you
understand I saw both of them today
intermesh well he's calling for a faster
a just a brutal shutdown and then open
up maybe a little bit faster so you know
this is that fine fine line look we did
a big shutdown when we wouldn't allow
people from China that could have been
very seriously infected that were when
we cut that off very early and then we
cut Europe off very early as you know so
that was also a new start opening Main
Street well I can't tell you that what I
have to say is that I think we're gonna
have good results I think the American
people have been amazing
I think our stimulus package will get
done and it will be a tremendous package
we're really not I mean they may not
have gotten those votes but they're very
close to getting a deal done so I'd be
I'd be surprised if they didn't and if
they don't I think frankly the American
people would be very upset with the
Democrats because the Republicans are
ready to approve a deal so the only
reason if the deal couldn't get done is
pure politics
New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio he
says that the city is gonna run out of
basic hospital supplies by April how do
you prevent New York City from becoming
the next Italy well he should have you
know the hospital systems in various
places some have been stocked and ready
to go for nothing for this nothing this
is beyond anything that anybody ever
thought possible I think you could
really say this nobody can nobody can
really doctor nobody can really say oh
gee this will happen this is a very
unique and hopefully it will be unique
for you know many many centuries you
know for a long time hopefully we don't
see this again but again the systems are
supposed to be ready willing and able
they're supposed to be ready to go we
are helping them a lot and I have great
love for New York City and I have great
love for New York State and we're gonna
help them a lot I mean I was just saying
we're sending our ships up there we're
sending on more than just this ship we
may be using if we need we'll be using
some of the cruise ships that you've
been reading about we'll be using them
also because they're very immediate and
very quick they can be there very
quickly we have good docking system you
know systems and the places that we're
talking about so we may be using some of
the cruise liners that we're talking
about but no I mean I think I think Bill
DeBlasio is working very hard I think
he's trying very hard it's a tough
situation for him and every mayor
because nobody has ever seen the scale
you know when you hear you've given
millions of masks and you've given
hundreds of thousands of masks in a
certain short period of time and then
you hear they need many many more you
know one of the things they have started
with respect to masks is the
sterilization process some are you know
really it works very well others aren't
really set up that way you throw them
out but we have a sterilization process
that's working very hard speaking of
that hand sanitizers you know when you
ask the question on the companies and
what's going on we have many companies
now companies that made whiskey that
made alcohol they've now gone very
quickly into the hand sanitizers and all
of you know you've been reading about
three or four big companies we're doing
incredibly well on that there was no way
if you took the existing companies that
something like that could happen but it
happens almost they'll call Peter
Navarro or they'll call somebody in one
case they called me they said we can do
this we can do that we've had a lot of
those calls where companies want to
there's a company in New Hampshire a
great company they want to make
ventilators I'd never thought of them
for that place but they do make metal
equipment and things out of metal
they'll be great they'll make they'll
make a great product so Peter I think
you're seeing a lot of that hundreds of
billions of dollars for the Treasury
Department to use to bail out states and
localities as well as specific
industries such as cruises and hotels
will you commit publicly that you know
that taxpayer money will go towards your
own yeah every time I do it like for
instance I committed publicly that I
wouldn't take the four hundred and fifty
thousand dollar salary it's a lot of
money whether you're richer now it's a
lot of money and I did it nobody cared
nobody nobody said thank you
nobody said thank you very much no I
didn't commit legal I just said I don't
want it I don't want my salary I work
for zero I don't want my salary
nobody said oh thank you very much but I
guarantee you if I ever took it you
would go out after me you in particular
would go out after me like crazy so I
have no idea what they're talking about
with regard to the one element
everything's changing just so you
understood so changing but I have no
idea but every time I commit to do
something that committed to do me look I
ran and everybody knew I was a rich
person I built a great company and
people knew that but I agreed to do
things I didn't have to I still don't
have to but my company I told the kids
who are running it I'm not running it
but I told him don't deal with foreign
companies don't do I didn't have to do
that I could have just ran and I have I
didn't have to do that at all and
instead of being thanked for again not
agreeing to do it but just for not doing
it
I get excoriated all the time
so I've learned let's just see what
happens because we have to save some of
these great companies that can be great
companies literally in a matter of weeks
we have to save them yeah please okay so
you would said that there would be eight
large medical structures that will be
built in California with more than two
thousand beds and then I think I heard
you say there would be four small
medical structures in the state of
Washington with 250 beds and we could
you say what cities in areas those are
going to be in specifically so we are
filling the governor's request and so we
send that resource to them they'll put
it the best use they'll put it to where
they will have the most effect so we
don't dictate exactly where it goes
again it's a request from the state to
the federal government for a certain
asset and those assets are sent to the
the GUP the governor can use it as he
sees fit and you're still considering
you just said that using the cruise
ships as well so I hope we don't need
them I hope you're gonna have great luck
on Tuesday morning we sent a lot of the
medicine we don't have to go into it
again but we sent a lot of the medicine
to Governor Cuomo I believe they already
have it and they have some very capable
people we spoke to dr. Zucker who is his
primary representative on this and we
spoke to the governor himself and I
think he's excited about it like I'm
excited about it now will it work I
think it has a really good chance I
think it's worth well why should we be
testing it in a test tube for a year and
a half when we have thousands of people
that are very sick they're very very
sick and we can use it on those people
and maybe make them better and in some
cases maybe save their lives so Governor
Cuomo told me they'll be using their
supply starting the supply and Tuesday
morning I think it's very exciting I
think because if that happens much of
what we're talking about with ships and
hospitals and all of the things that
we're doing
and all of these masks and everything
that we're ordering ventilators it's a
whole different game if that happens and
we'll see there's been some tremendous
signs that this could work now again you
know some doctors think it should go for
years and testing but you know this has
been something that's been around for
many years it's been phenomenal strong
powerful drug from malaria but we think
it might work on this based on evidence
based on very strong evidence we're
gonna see we're going to know on you
know sometime after Tuesday but you'll
have to ask Governor Cuomo I think
they're gonna start the process we've
gotten them the drug I think they're
going to start the process of giving the
drug mouth you know through through
mouth and I think that starts on Tuesday
morning he said and that'll be I mean
I'll tell you what I don't want to get
anybody overly excited but I'm very
excited by that by the prospect of it
then in addition to that their work in
NIH is working on vaccines and on that
making great progress but the vaccine
does have to be tested for a long period
of time because you can't give you know
thousands millions of people a vaccine
and it turns out to be dangerous so that
does have to be tested but this one's
been taken for a long time so we know
pretty much one result yeah please China
and President Xi when was the last time
you had a conversation oh I don't want
to exactly say that but I have spoken to
President Xi about this specifically
about this and look he doesn't want this
you know this is not something that he
wants and and it happened it happened to
China and one thing they told me I was
told by a great Secretary of Agriculture
sonny Perdue that China has been buying
a lot of our farm product and I'm
looking at different pricing but China
has despite all of this and it started
this delayed it a little bit obviously
but it started fairly recently but
China's buying we made a new deal as you
know with China very big trade deal and
China has been buying our agricultural
product
masks I mean they've been a supplier of
the United States of mask of yes in fact
they sent me some masks ascending master
Italy they are sending masks to Italy
we're in a very good process with masks
but I'm a little upset with China I'll
be honest with you because as much as I
I like President Xi and as much as I
respect the country and and admire the
country I've great admiration for the
country what they've done in short
period of time of course our presidents
our previous presidents allowed that to
happen you should say thank you very
much to all of them but they should have
told us about this and I did ask him
whether or not we could send some people
in they didn't want that at a pride I
think really at a price they don't want
they don't want to sending people into
China to help them you know China's
strong country they have they have their
scientists and they have their doctors
very smart a lot of people are you know
but I did discuss that about sending our
people in and they didn't really respond
we went again they didn't respond if
they went in they would have been able
to tell us give us so much earlier
indication but we had an early
indication that's why I closed out China
I mean I felt it was my instinct but
that's why I closed out China at a very
early time please our undocumented
persons welcome at testing sites and can
they show up and be tested without fear
of being reported to immigration
officials for possibly it's really a
fair question I think I'll let we know
from a public health perspective that it
is important that people who have
symptoms can get tested but as you heard
earlier we are prep well we know that if
the virus doesn't judge based on where
you're from and so it's important that
we try to get people tested who has
symptoms but the important thing that we
really want people to hear is that in
patients need to be tested we need to
prioritize our health care workers and
one thing I would like to say to you all
very quickly on behalf of the doctors on
the task force health care workers we
hear you
we hear you and we absolutely are
prioritizing your health in safety
making sure health care workers can get
tested in patients can get tested people
at highest risk but to answer your
question yes we absolutely want to make
sure people who have symptoms who could
be spreading it can get tested
Department of Homeland Security
addressed that issue a few days ago
Customs and Border Protection actually
issued guidance that absent certain
circumstances the Customs and Border
Protection does not target emergency
rooms or health clinics and I would
refer you to the website they issued a
very clear statement making it making it
clear to any person that is in need of a
test or medical care that Customs and
Border Protection is not focusing on
emergency rooms or health clinics or the
drive-thru clinics without fear of yes
and that's not the policy I'll make it
the policy and I was just saying as Mike
was saying that the answer is yes we
will do those tests because I think in
that case it's important I think that if
you could go you could say illegal alien
you could say illegal immigrant you
could say whatever you want to use your
definition of what you're talking about
we're all talking about the same thing
yes we will test that person because I
think it's important that we test that
person and we don't want to send that
person back in to wherever we're going
to be sending the person whether it's
another country or someplace else
because you know we're now bringing them
right out of our country but yeah we
will test those people okay we were talk
about this before the briefing you know
a lot of folks there watching TV they're
reading up on this constantly if you are
not and you know somebody who's got a
pre-existing health condition but you
all of a sudden go you know sighs I just
don't feel a hundred percent and then
your mind just starts playing with you
right you think oh my god you know I
coughed three hours ago was that a first
time we
should those people really start to say
okay maybe I need to call the doctors so
you don't want to flood them but a lot
of people that are that are probably
healthy right now are thinking whoa
that's all I'm hearing about it's all I
can think about when should I
either call a doctor or get tested the
vice president gave an important
statistic this morning only 10% of the
people who have symptoms who've been
tested actually tested positive for
coronavirus meaning nine out of ten
people who actually likely had symptoms
do not have the corona virus so I want
people to understand that so that they
are reassured I also want to direct
people to a website we've been telling
them about all the time
coronavirus gov coronavirus gov has
information to walk you through the
symptoms fever cough shortness of breath
body aches and what to do if you have
symptoms or you're worried the most
important thing we can tell people is
call your health care provider talk to
your health care provider information
that coronavirus gov to walk you through
when to come in and win and what to do
yesterday
I'm just jerky tell us what that was
like for you you get a lot of people are
gonna be going through this but we stand
by the phone where you just didn't have
a nice TV what did you yeah what was
that like and what did you do that kind
of until that time to keep your mind at
ease the test was very quick but it goes
a fair amount up into your sinuses and
it's not comfortable and that's the
reason it probably is a good opportunity
to say again to any American looking on
if you don't have symptoms you don't
need to test and current testing format
although they're evolving regularly now
we just mentioned that I think at the
end of this week there'll be a new test
and there's all new technologies I would
say again to all the governors that are
looking on and their state health
officials contact FEMA will give you all
the latest information on new testing
that is available including steps we're
making where Americans would be able to
test themselves and send it in but
well for me and mrs. pence it was a it
was kind of a pinch it was kind of
invasive but we were grateful for the
support Walter Reed Hospital processed
the tests very quickly they had a lab at
the hospital to be able to do that and
gave us the results quickly but it also
informed me we we were wondering during
that time as a family and it's one of
the reasons that presidents made it such
a priority that we brought all these
commercial labs together and now more
than a quarter million tests have been
done we believe we'll be caught up if
you will by the middle of this week on a
backlog of tests but we announced today
that we are directing commercial labs to
prioritize people who are in the
hospital for tests is we want to
continue to work with new technology and
with the new focus and guides from HHS
to get the results of that as quickly as
possible for every American so if they
have coronavirus they can be properly
treated or they can have the peace of
mind that they may have some other
respiratory ailment but not that Karen
pence knows this because the vice
president told me he said she actually
held it better than Pelosi earlier today
said that the house may introduce its
own bill a are you willing to work with
the speaker on a House bill and given
what happened in the Senate just a short
time ago what are you willing to do to
get this bill over the finish line given
the urgency secondly did you send a
letter to North Korea's Kim jong-un
seeking cooperation with numerous
countries if they need help we'll give
them help there's nobody has what we
have especially with the new tests that
are coming out North Korea Iran by the
way and others we are open for helping
other countries and there's a very
serious time in North Korea's going
through something around
going through something very very strong
we let ran is really going through a
very difficult period with respect to
this as you know so I've put the it's
really a glad-hand it's all it is to
North Korea to Iran and to many other
countries and we're working with as the
doctor can say we're working with many
countries with respect to the problems
that they have again it's a over 140
countries right now but North Korea Iran
and many other countries we will help
and we're willing to as an example this
new test if this new test works out
where instead of going through what we
all went through with this rather
difficult test to put it nicely we would
have is that just a swab on the tongue
doctor just a how does that work not to
the same it doesn't go all the way up
and hangs a right under your eye right
so that's a tough test so if we do that
that the procedure the test and nobody
has this in the world nobody has this
this is developed by us we think it's
going to be certified shoot soon we
think it's going to be very good but if
we have that we'll be able to help a lot
of countries for something please just
develop on that are you willing to work
we have to we have to help the American
worker we have to help the countries
from which the American workers I mean
they came out of these companies that
were doing phenomenally well you saw
what payroll was going way up where
wages were going way way up there's
never been a time like this
we can't lose those companies and we
want the worker to be happy and whipping
I think more generous than anybody has
ever been we want to take care of the
worker but we want to make sure that
when we win the war it's only a question
of when not if when we win the war
against the virus we want to make sure
those companies are ready to charge
forward not that they've been disbanded
because we were penny wise and dollar
foolish there are factors around the
world that produced
protective equipment that are used in
European hospitals they've been
certified for use and at the highest
level in European hospitals is the FDA
and your administration willing to look
at a waiver for that equipment to be
sold from those facts well where's that
question a little while ago and the
answer is we may but we may not need it
we do a very high standard or standard
is higher please mr. president I was
hoping to give some guidance to American
families who are anxious about their
financial futures earlier today on one
of the Sunday morning shows the
secretary of the Treasury Steve minutia
was talking about the millions of
Americans who are impacted by these
shutdowns that are happening in cities
and sometimes full states yeah and
Secretary manoosh in said that this
shutdown this lockdown could last 10 to
12 weeks perhaps early into June given
that would you consider another fiscal
stimulus another check to these gonna
see what happens hopefully we won't need
it but we might but we're gonna see what
happens look the greatest thing we can
do is win the war the war is against the
virus that's the war we do that
everything I really believe everything's
gonna fall into place it's going to be
beautiful I call it a pent up demand
people are dying to go out to a
restaurant people are dying to go onto
airplanes and I think well there's a
tremendous pent up demand you may be
surprised to the degree I think it's
going to go very rapidly because this
wasn't a financial crisis just the
opposite this was a medical crisis I own
advances don't even think about it you
know it's very interesting that you ask
a question like that you know nasty
question and yet it deserves to be asked
I guess what I've done by deciding to
run I knew this I knew this the first
day I said if I win it's gonna cost a
lot of money it cost me billions of
dollars to become president to be
president of the United States in things
that would normally be run at a certain
thing even people that don't like me
because they think I'm too tough on the
border now some people love me for it
other people don't like me at all you
know it's very funny my wife we were at
a charity event
in New York City I had just announced
that I was running and we were at the
Robin Hood Foundation at the Convention
Center which now we're going to be
converting to hospitals for Governor
Cuomo and I was walking in and there was
a smattering of boos and a smattering of
cheers I was getting both and are very
popular first lady she's turned out to
be a very popular people have great
respect for her but a very popular first
lady said to me huh that's strange I've
never heard anybody booing you that was
very early on because I think I called
for strong borders right call for
something that other people don't like
you know and I knew this would happen I
knew it was gonna happen but the fact
that I ran and I knew as soon as they
announced when I ran I said it's going
to cost me a fortune not only in terms
of actual cost look at my legal costs
you people everybody everybody is suing
me I'm being sued by people that I never
even heard of I'm being sued all over
the place and doing very well but it's
unfair but I say this in terms of
running for president and I don't think
rich people Michael Bloomberg spent now
always determine almost a billion
dollars and look what happened I think
it's very hard for rich people to run
for office it's it's far more costly
it's it's just a
it's a very tough thing now with all of
that being said I'm so glad I've done it
because you know there's a lot of rich
people around got a lot of rich friends
but they can't help and they can't do
what I've done in terms of helping this
country we are we are doing things we
got sidetracked by the invisible enemy
but you know what when you look at what
we've done I said before with the
veterans with with all of the things
we've done especially choice but when
you look at all of accountability when
you look at all of the things that we've
done rebuilding the military the tax
cuts which thank goodness we had the tax
cuts because we had cushion oh and
without that this would have been
catastrophic
we had a big cushion I mean with all of
the losses that you've seen in the stock
market we're basically back and with
this horrible thing if this would have
happened before you would have had
nothing left this was all cushion but I
will say that it costs me billions of
dollars to be president and especially
with all the money I could have made for
the last three four years and I didn't
because I was being president I have no
interest in it I'm allowed to you know I
don't know if you know George Washington
they say he was a rich man supposedly
relatively rich and he ran the
presidency and he also ran his business
they say he had two desks nobody
complained until I came along I got
elected as a rich person but nobody
complained until I came along so it cost
me billions of dollars to be president
and I am so happy I did it because who
cares who cares I'm really happy with
the job we're doing and I'm glad that
this team and me are here for this
horrible thing I mean it's a number of
people have said it but and I feel it
actually I'm a wartime president this is
a war this is a war different kind of a
war that we've ever had and when you
look at the economics of the war in the
past we used to stimulate to get people
jobs now we're stimulating to protect
people because we don't want them to
work because we want them to stay away
from each other we don't want them to
gather social so social gathering
so we're paying billions of dollars more
than that so that they don't gather they
don't because we have to defeat this
virus and we will but it costs me
billions and billions of dollars to be
president and I am so happy I did it I
realize that your priority is to
Americans and of course this nation but
what about have you ever considered
supporting the foreign countries who are
also fighting this global pandemic that
was the other question and I'm honored
to help and the doctor has helped the
Surgeon General is speaking to other
countries all the time they're asking
him questions what do we do nobody has
ever seen anything like this they're
calling our people all of the time and
yes I have let it be known that will
help people including North Korea
including Iran and including many other
countries it's very important to do that
are you considering any financial
support for them let me quote to you on
to retired retired general and a retired
Admiral from the u.s. global coalition
on no matter how successful we are in
fighting the threat of Kovach 19
pandemic at home will never stop and
unless we're also fighting it around the
world so financially is there anything
in the stimulus bill and then are you
considering no not in the stimulus bill
but we are very much I mean we give away
billions of dollars for as an example
AIDS in Africa we're still fighting that
battle it's a tremendous battle
tremendous war also but we're fighting
it here as you know in 10 years now it's
eight years because I started it should
have been started before long before I
got here because they had the answer
even before but we're fighting that
battle will be aids-free in
approximately eight years it looks like
that is going to happen we're spending a
lot of money but we're spending a lot of
money with other countries if you look
at the aid that we give to other
countries we give billions and billions
and billions of dollars to other
countries and a lot of times I say you
know we could save a lot of money we
shouldn't and then they come in I say
what's it used for it's used to fight
malaria it's in countries that are very
poor it's used to fight AIDS in Africa
it's used to fight many other things
many other things and I don't
i've ever said no i can't it's just so
terrible countries that we have really
were not involved with them very much
other than there would be tremendous
death tremendous death I mean you can
get a list and I could get you a list we
give away billions of dollars to other
countries and we are giving away a lot
in terms of everything and probably will
end up doing economically doing
something for other countries but when
I'm presented with these lists that yes
they're in Africa were fighting AIDS or
were fighting something else I tell you
what I start off by saying you know we
should say we could save a lot of money
and then by the time they walk those
listen to my office I say we have to
keep doing that that's humanity you're
talking how about one more question yes
person I want to ask you about the
states that have not yet issued stay at
home waters so in Texas for example the
hospitals have said that they expect to
run out of beds by the end of April if
the governor does not issue a state on
order Dallas County just announced an
order it's very it's not a septic oh
that's a great governor you're talking
about Greg Abbott Abbott in Texas and
he's a great governor and he knows what
he's doing a lot of the areas that he's
talking about a lot of the counties he's
talking about are not very strongly
affected you know it's very different
kind of a place in a great place but I
have total confidence in Governor Greg
you're okay with Idaho West Virginia
Iowa Nebraska are much different than
New York then California Los Angeles as
an example or San Francisco they're much
different I mean it's it's much
different the hot spots right now our
state of Washington and probably number
one by far right now is New York that's
a hot spot like no other hot spot in
California Zod's but but New York right
now is is the leader there's no question
our final coordinate you sir your
administration is backing a lawsuit to
invalidate the Affordable Care Act given
that people are losing their jobs now in
the
carry more than ever would you consider
rethinking your position on that well
that's a lawsuit coming out of Texas
again that was headed up by Texas and
what we want to do is get rid of the bad
health care and put in a great health
care and we will always I will say this
I can make this commitment to you the
Republican Party is fully backing
pre-existing conditions now if we could
get a great health care plan which would
need the house to do but if we can get a
great health care plan we will only do
it if we have pre-existing conditions
totally back so we're backing
pre-existing but would like to get rid
of bad health care now we are running
the bad health care much better than it
was ever run and we're making it better
but it could be much better than it is
and so what we want to do is terminate
it have a great health care but we will
only do it with pre-existing we will
back pre-existing conditions ok what if
this thing thank you all very much thank
you we'll be back we'll have a meeting
tomorrow
okay thank you for you donate blood
donate blood